we've got ed O'Keefe also here in Des
Moines he's been covering every aspect
of this race from the very beginning ed
good morning how do you think it's going
to shake out tonight
well good morning Tony the words of
today are expect anything that's just
the way politics is these days but if
you look at CBS news polling there is
perhaps a roadmap of what to expect
tonight Bernie Sanders could come out on
top if there's signs of record high
turnout it could also benefit mayor Pete
Buda Jets both have focused on turning
out younger and first-time caucus goers
but our polling also shows Joe Biden has
a strong chance of winning in part
because he's the second choice of many
caucus goers who were first set to
support candidates polling in the single
digits and aren't likely to meet the
minimum threshold of 15 percent they'll
be invited to make a second choice and
many are expected to switch to Biden one
of the things that has struck us here in
recent days is that all the talk about
the issues has been pushed aside to
focus instead on electability or the
ability to defeat President Trump in
November and remember despite all the
attention on Iowa in recent months just
41 delegates of the 1990 needed to win
the Democratic nomination are up for
grabs tonight Tony a reminder we still
have a long way to go we do indeed thank
you very much
you